un drone vient de s'abattre sur la
raffinerie d'ilski dans la région de
Krasnodar déclenchant un gigantesque
incendie
1000 km plus au nord c'est la ville de
chébekino qui s'est retrouvé pilonné
dans la région de Belgorod qui a reçu
pas moins de 260 tirs de mortier et
d'artillerie il était 3h15 du matin une
attaque massive de missile a frappé chez
béquino il y a beaucoup de destruction
des appartements des maisons des
voitures brûlées
le Kremlin immédiatement accusé
l'Ukraine d'être à l'origine de ses
attaques une version démenti par Kiev
comme c'est systématiquement le cas
quand la Russie est touchée le point
commun entre toutes ces frappes elle se
situe dans ces zones frontalières avec
l'Ukraine et vise particulièrement la
région de Belgorod qui subit ces
dernières semaines des attaques
quasiment quotidiennes la plus
spectaculaire la semaine dernière quand
des soldats arborant les couleurs de
l'Ukraine se filment blindé sur les
routes de belgorodes une incursion sans
précédent en territoire russe la
frontière est ouverte et grand-père
Poutine dort pour toujours
comment interpréter la multiplication de
de ces attaques dans cette zone
frontalière côté russe y a-t-il un lien
avec la grande contre-offensive
ukrainienne annonçait comme imminente
depuis plusieurs semaines la stratégie
ukrainienne pour préparer la
contre-attaque ce sont des frappes
stratégiques que ce soit des attentats
que font des résistants en Ukraine ou en
Russie que ce soit des frappes avec des
missiles où là des frappes avec des
drones c'est une façon aussi d'inquiéter
la Russie ça c'est la stratégie
ukrainienne signe de l'inquiétude qui
s'installe dans la région de Belgorod
300 enfants ont dû être évacués de deux
localités régulièrement frappées ils ont
été installés dans une ville située à
plus de 250 km de la frontière